[Musique]
le bonsoir à tous mardi 19 février
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité locale
en 26 minutes tout de suite les titres
de cette édition
les actes antisémites en recrudescence
ils ont augmenté de 74% en france l'an
passé alors qu'une marche pour contrer
le phénomène se déroule ce soir partout
en france les habitants et représentants
des cultes de poissy se sont réunis dès
dimanche
invité de ce journal le rabbin saint
quentinois mendel ni sam baum 1er
janvier 2020 date de la naissance
officielle de l'université paris saclay
cet établissement de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche dont l'ue
vs qu constitueront notamment cette
entité un point d'étape a été fait ce
matin par les acteurs du dossier à paris
nous étions sur place
et puis à trois jours de l'ouverture du
salon de l'agriculture direction
auffargis une ferme s'est engagé dans
cette démarche une production
respectueuse de l'animal et de
l'environnement le site a reçu récemment
la visite de la députée des yvelines
aurore bergé des actes antisémites en
augmentation d'après les derniers
chiffres révélés dernière en date la
profanation aujourd'hui dans un
cimetière juif
en alsace on parle de ce phénomène avec
mon invité le rabbin mendel nice mboum
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le délégué du
beth loubavitch à montigny le bretonneux
alors pour contrer ce phénomène
d'antisémitisme des marches sont
organisées partout en france ce soir une
union contre l'antisémitisme à l'appel
de 14 partis politiques et dimanche
c'est à à poissy que l'on organisait un
rassemblement en présence des
représentants des cultes religieux
le reportage de patrick jacques de
dixmude et de mélanie poquet ils ont
planté un érable pour la paix
les représentants des différents cultes
pisciacais ont répondu présent après les
événements contre des lieux de culte de
mémoire qu'ont connu la france et les
yvelines
je trouve formidable que le maire car
monsieur karl olive et répondu
elle appelle à sa façon la pelle que
j'avais lancé que chaque mairie plante
un arbre
et puis on a senti les vibrations de
fraternité ici par delà les cultes d un
d autre part de la même l'absence de
religion mais la volonté de vivre
quelque chose ensemble
la partie cachée étant la racine
c'est-à-dire la filiation
quant aux deux autres partis il y a le
tronc est allé branches et quand les
branchés chamaillent c'est parce qu'ils
ont oublié de tron le trempant lequel
qui les supportent et là faut dire stop
parce que la france l'autre belle
république ce n'est pas cela la france
il faut se tenir debout pour le bien
vivre fraternellement sans vous nous
sommes juifs nous sommes catholiques
nous sommes musulmans nous sommes flics
nous sommes protestants nous sommes
tolérants
nous sommes ensemble c'est au coeur du
jardin de l'olivier que l' arbre a été
planté un lieu pensé par les cultes
monothéistes et la ville de poissy en
il est nécessaire je pense que nous
montrons que nous montrons que chaque
fois que quelqu un d eux est attaqué et
atteint montrer notre notre union notre
désaccord nôtres
notre fraternité doit s'exercer au
quotidien dans des petits gestes en 2018
les actes à caractère antisémite était
en hausse de 74%
le rabbin mendel nice album en plateau
avec moi délégué du beth loubavitch de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une réaction
sur ce sujet déjà c'est important qu'il
y ait ce genre de rassemblement
évidemment ce genre de rassemblement est
extrêmement important puisque ça montre
justement qu'on veut combattre
l'intolérance
on sait que notre république est juste
pour la tolérance
toutes les communautés ont toujours vécu
ensemble en france à paris et même à
saint quentin en yvelines
donc ce rassemblement montre bien qu'on
est tous pour la tolérance et pour le
même but avec la présence des élus vous
parler des autres cultes religieux aussi
on a parlé de sur ce plateau à semaine
dernière des actes islamophobes
il faut que les religions soit unie face
à ce genre d'actes qui sont perpétrés en
france
oui bien sûr puisque c'est pas ces
antisémite anti-juif cette fois ci mais
c'est de les religions en soi qui sont
concernés c'est toutes les religions
ensemble nous avons besoin d'être unie
un combat qui devait être ensemble pour
la tolérance pour qu'on puisse accepter
les uns les autres qu'on puisse accepter
majoritairement les religions s'accepte
les religieuses accepte il ya quelques
mouvance divers et variés par ci par là
mais on doit montrer qu'elle est le vrai
chemin mais vous l'avez dit à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ses relations
entre les religions marche très bien
c'est un exemple ici à 50 ans cinquante
ans nouvelle est un très bel exemple
puisqu'il y a
il n'y a pas de problème sur saint
quentin en yvelines
que ce soit au niveau antisémite ou même
niveau juifs notre local ici et tout
prix l'église évangélique ce donc il n'y
a vraiment aucun problème ce soir
démarche partout en france organisée
dont la principale à paris place de la
république la meilleure réponse à
apporter c'est que les personnes
viennent en nombre pour pour se
rassembler oui bien sûr que les
personnes viennent en nombre pour bien
montrer que ces groupuscules où ces
personnes isolées restent vraiment des
personnes isolées et que nous sommes
réparé la tolérance pour le vivre
ensemble
je disais tout à l'heure recrudescence
des actes antisémites en france en 2018
+74 % de nouveaux cas qui sont qu'ils
ont été
ray perpétré la semaine dernière ces
derniers jours l'inscription du mot juif
en allemand sur une enseigne à paris
l'arbre planté aussi en mémoire d'ilan
halimi en essonne qui a été retrouvée
ciller les portraits de simone veil
recouvert de croix gammées et ce
cimetière juif profané aujourd'hui en
alsace quand vous aviez tous ces actes
plus de soixante dix ans après la shoah
quel est votre sentiment
alors il ya un sentiment je vais je vais
dire d'inquiétude
un sentiment d'inquiétude parce que
l'histoire du peuple juif en france est
très ancienne depuis le moyen âge
il ya le grand auteur rachis qui vivait
à troyes en champagne qui était un
vignoble donc l'histoire du peuple
atchan france est très ancien et
toujours en a toujours eu des juifs en
france et la france fait partie aussi de
notre histoire de notre vie nous avons
toujours vécu en france
c'est la raison pour laquelle s'il ya eu
aujourd'hui cette inquiétude qui est de
ce vivre ensemble qui a aujourd'hui
remis en question une inquiétude
justement vous qui êtes au contact de la
communauté juive de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est aussi ce que ressentent
ses fidèles en ce moment c'est
l'inquiétude c'est le sentiment qui
ressort
oui c'est à dire on est préoccupé on
veille l'histoire on veut voir comment
ça donc comment ça va sortir en fin de
compte qu'est ce que ça va donner
bien sûr évidemment il n'y a pas de
vraie crainte la république fait tout en
sorte pour que les choses se passent
bien
les forces de l'ordre ont toujours
présente donc il n'y a pas de peur il
n'y a pas de crainte mais une inquiétude
et s'il ya aussi une peur d'exercer son
culte où on en est pas encore à ce camp
là tout de même nom donc comme je disais
n'y a pas de peur on regarde il y a un
regard il y à une altitude mais pas de
peur alors des actions spontanées ou
organisées pour soutenir la communauté
juive
des gestes qui reste symbolique est ce
qu'il ya selon vous des choses à faire
peut-être davantage de sensibilisation
d'éducation aussi auprès des plus jeunes
que les actions pourraient être mis en
place pour endiguer ce genre de
phénomène tout d'abord bien sûr qu'il ya
des actions de sensibilisation qui
doivent être faites expliqué dire
raconté par les se soit fait dans les
écoles tout soit fait pour les plus
jeunes que ce soit fait dans les mains
dans le milieu social il faut que ce
soit fait pour comprendre qu' il y a des
différences il ya des personnes qui
vivent différemment
mais ce n'est pas pour autant qu'elles
sont réellement différente on peut tous
vivre ensemble exactement de la même
manière
justement savoir reconnaître l'autre et
le connaître également est en tout cas
une un projet qui est en réflexion celui
de pénaliser l'antisionisme c'est à dire
le fait d'être hostiles à l'état
d'israël la question est porté par un
député de la république en marché est ce
que c'est une bonne solution est ce que
finalement l'antisionisme c'est de
l'antisémitisme
si on regarde l'antisionisme en soit on
peut dire non mais si on regarde
réellement sur les faits tout ce qui a
touché l'antisionisme a touché
l'antisémitisme n'y avoir pas eu de
différence aujourd'hui un amalgame entre
de monk l'antisionisme est devenu lé
anti juif et donc antisémite
c'est pour ça pénalisée ou pas je ne
sais pas mais en tout état de cause
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les deux
choses se ressemblent et se semble elle
même c'est à dire que c'est exactement
mêmes faits c'est un projet qui en tout
cas en réflexion si on doit terminer cet
entretien vos espérances sur sur ce
phénomène
quels sont vos espérances aujourd'hui
mes espérances
c'est qu'on puisse revivre tous ensemble
j'ai grandi à paris je suis né en france
et je vais y rester
je veux qu'on puisse continuer à vivre
dans cette harmonie comme ça toujours
été et faire grandir mes enfants
exactement de la même manière
merci mendel nice mboum d'être passé sur
ce plateau arabe un délégué du beth
loubavitch à montigny le bretonneux
dans l'actualité du jour l'accusation
d'une avocats du barreau de paris qui
vise le tribunal de grande instance de
versailles dans les colonnes du parisien
caroline mécary dénonce l'attitude du tj
sur la question de l'adoption
homoparentale selon elle dans le cas
d'un couple homosexuel le tribunal
s'opposerait systématiquement à l'heure
de l'adoption par le conjoint d'un
enfant né d'une pma une magistrate
ferait prévaloir son opinion personnelle
sur le sujet d'après l'avocate est de
son côté la chancellerie du tgi se
défend en indiquant que tout jugement
rendu son motivée par des arguments de
droit
le projet de l'université paris saclay
se dévoile ce mastodonte de
l'enseignement supérieur doit voir le
jour le 1er janvier 2020 trois
universités dont l'ue vs q4 grandes
écoles et des organismes de recherche
qui composeront
au total cette entité de 65 mille
étudiants ce matin à paris sur le campus
agroparistech les différents acteurs du
dossier ont fait le point et nous avons
interrogé la présidente de l'université
les images sont signées nicolas landry
un pas de plus chaque mois d'ici 2020
l'université paris saclay qui se
formalise qui se construit petit à petit
pour une naissance au 1er janvier 2020
bonjour sylvie retailleau
bonjour toute récente présidente de
l'université paris 5 alors à quelques
mois de la naissance de cet
établissement où en est-on concrètement
aujourd'hui
alors on en est sur une trajectoire
concrète de la création comme vous
l'avez dit de l'université paris saclay
qui va se faire officiellement au 1er
janvier mais que l'on préfigure déjà
cette année on a déjà depuis 2015 des
mentions de master des écoles doctorales
et là on construit pour déposer des
maquettes en juin les licences les
mastères les écoles doctorales de
l'université paris saclay et la
cartographie des 280 laboratoire qui
vont constituer cette grande université
paris saclay qui va se mettre en place
au 1er janvier des universités membres
au début comme l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines qui seront
intégrés progressivement d'ici 2025
les premiers objectifs quels sont ils
pour cette université les premiers
objectifs c'est vraiment et c'est un
objectif partagé entre ces trois
universités puisque je compte paris sud
qui va se fondre dans paris saclay et
les deux universités dans un premier
temps evry et versa partenaires mais qui
vont s'intégrer en 2025 et les quatre
écoles et c'est un objectif partagé de
vraiment encore plus mettre au coeur
l'étudiant la formation dans toutes ses
diversités et une recherche de très haut
niveau qui va avoir effectivement une
répercussion hydre et nommé un
rayonnement mondial et je pense que
c'est d'abord et en ambition partagée de
l'évolution de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche française
mais vous l'avez dit même si cette
université naîtra au 1er janvier il ya
déjà des diplômes qui sont délivrés tout
à fait la commune qui est un
établissement epscp donc avec ledroit
d'accréditer des livres et des livres
déjà aujourd'hui 100% de nos écoles de
nos diplômes de doctorat et donc avec
les écoles doctorales commune en gros
80% des mentions de master sont dès
aujourd'hui commun
donc c'est vraiment une co-construction
progressive et c'est pour ça que cette
université sera d'ailleurs une
université expérimental et au 1er
janvier 2020 c'est un nouveau pas
concret fort mais qui va continuer à
évoluer pendant les dix ans
d'expérimentation de cette université
alors dans cette université paris saclay
trois universités quatre grandes écoles
des organismes de recherche également
comment on harmonise le tout commence et
c'est possible d'harmoniser le tout
alors comment on harmonise le taux je
crois naturellement en essayant de
partager des valeurs de donner un sens
au projet avec les communautés et devoir
pour chacun la valeur ajoutée et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui alors on a ces
quatre écoles et trois universités qui
formeront vraiment les membres
fondateurs de l'université paris saclay
et on a la chance mais parce qu'on l'a
créé nos chercheurs l'ont créé d'avoir
le partenariat très fort avec nos six
plus lit hs organismes nationaux de
recherche qui ne sont pas intégrés
évidemment dans l'université paris
saclay mais qui sont qu'avec un
partenariat je dirais non pas classique
comme toute université mais renforcée
donc ensuite ce sont ces acteurs
d'écoles et d'universités et c'est une
étape d'acculturation que nous
commençons à construire pour vraiment
aux bénéfices d'abord de l'étudiant des
étudiants de la recherche et du monde
socio économique avec les défis et les
enjeux que nous allons relever et 10,6
1er janvier 2020 quelles sont les étapes
des ans mais quel est le calendrier
alors le calendrier ben il est en cours
il ya bien sûr les statuts qui vont être
un moment fort on va voter les statuts
et dans les ca
les conseils d'administration de tous
nos établissements autour de l'été avant
l'été ce qui va nous permettre d'avoir
un décret de création on vise novembre
pour pouvoir voter lire les conseils le
conseil d'administration le conseil
académique de l'université paris saclay
avant noël pour pouvoir avoir la
création statutaire de cette université
en janvier 2020 deuxième calendrier
c'est la création concrète avec les
directions les services parce que
d'abord derrière l'université il ya des
gens des personnes qui font fonctionner
l'université est donc aujourd'hui on est
en train de construire non seulement
bien sûr les formations
labo avec les chercheurs les enseignants
chercheurs mais les personnels
administratifs et techniques qui font
toutes les fonctions support soutien qui
sont la force de notre université et
donc on est en mode préfiguration de ses
directions de ses fonctions communes de
ces mutualisations et on a aussi un
calendrier de préfigurateur de
directrice ou directeur général des
services préfigurateurs des directions
de services
et tout ça pour mars un paravent pour
mai juin juillet pour pouvoir commencer
à préfigurer le mode de fonctionnement
une dernière question il ya un deuxième
grand pôle qui est aussi en train de se
créer sur le plateau de saclay on a
connu le nom tout récemment au new unis
autour de l'école polytechnique
notamment comment va se placer
l'université paris saclay quelle
stratégie est ce que ça va être un
collaborateur
ce new unis où un concurrent donc le new
aunis tait le nom de code jusqu'à
maintenant aujourd'hui on sait qu'ils
s'appellent institut polytechnique de
paris
donc effectivement on aura trois
établissements issus de la commune
l'université paris saclay 20 avec les
membres dont on a parlé
l'institut polytechnique de paris et hec
qui faisait partie aussi de la commune
qui sera un troisième établissement
partenaire des deux autres étapes et
morges établissement aussi à l'orb à
l'institut polytechnique de paris
comme c'est un autre établissement
chacun aura sa stratégie donc
concurrence ou compétition comme tout
les établissements mais aujourd'hui pour
moi la compétition elle n'est absolument
pas nationale encore moins territoriale
elle est absolument à l'international et
donc il est évident que ça sera aussi un
partenaire fort par sa géographie par
son emplacement par sa puissance de
frappe comme le nôtre est d'abord un
partenaire pour que ce soit la france sa
formation et sa recherche qui rayonne à
l'international
merci sylvie retailleau président de
l'université paris saclay retenez cette
date le 1er janvier 2020 date de la
création officielle de cette université
et dans cet établissement l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
aura un statut particulier en janvier
elle sera universités membres son
intégration et sa disparition définitive
dans l'université paris saclay elle doit
intervenir au plus tard en 2025 écouté
les explications du président de l'ue vs
qu à l'ennui
et c'est quelque chose de totalement
inédit c'est un statut hybride qui n'est
jamais si jusqu'à maintenant ce qui fait
que l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines va à la fois
participer pleinement à la gouvernance
de la nouvelle université expérimental
paris-saclay dès 2020 tout en continuant
à exister en tant qu'université avec son
propre budget en gérant ses ressources
humaines et avec son autonomie donc
c'est juste une mécanique qui permet de
participer pleinement à la construction
de l'université dès 2020 et de préparer
notre intégration la fusion de
l'ensemble de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines vers
l'université paris saclay au plus tard
en 2025 l'eau et ce processus
d'intégration a déjà à démarrer
l'ensemble des doctorats et 70% des
mastères par l'ue vs qu sont déjà des
diplômes universitaires paris saclay une
formation numérique et prototypage
rapide enseignement organisée par le ski
lab delà de la derrière en collaboration
avec l'institut des mines télécom lé
projet dans le ce cadre ont été
restitués cette semaine la fin d'un
cycle de formation qui a duré quatre
mois pour ces demandeurs d'emploi
nicolas landry de la station
météorologique connecté à la boîte de
croquettes pour chat intelligente les
projets développés par les personnes en
formation au ski lab une formation à la
fabrication numérique et au prototypage
rapide
cette jardinière elle arrose
automatiquement les plantes avec ce
tonneau
grâce au capteur d'humidité qui se
trouve plainte est ici un capteur de
lumière pour pour apporter de la lumière
nécessaire à la planche elle est très
très orienté sur le travail collaboratif
donc elle permet vraiment d'expérimenter
le fait de travailler en groupe
toute la partie 3d qui a été pour moi
vraiment super intéressante avec la
fabrication de satisfaire en 3d et le
back log allemand et puis après j'ai des
composants comment comment genre un
programme comment on active ces 15
personnes demandeurs d'emploi ont suivi
une formation de quatre mois à travers
plusieurs mook des cours en ligne et des
ateliers au ski lab une formation menée
par l'institut mines télécom avec comme
objectif venir complémenter des
compétences pour avoir une meilleure
employabilité sur le marché de l'emploi
et donc retrouver facilement du travail
s'est associé aussi avec un lob 6,99 qui
est une entreprise sous
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui fait la
formation numérique et de la formation
au skylab est associée effet réalisé par
un bénévole et raymond qui est sa propre
société qui est 6,99 imprimante 3d
découpeuse laser brodeuses numérique et
robotique plusieurs machines au ski lab
de la verrière utilisé durant la
formation des outils toute l'année à
disposition des 300 membres de
l'association une certaine émotion hier
en salle du conseil municipal de trapel
ces pgc atm une association d'anciens
combattants a remis son drapeau à la
ville cette section d'anciens de la
seconde guerre mondiale et des conflits
en algérie tunisie et maroc a été créé à
trappes en 1997 elle n'a désormais plus
d'adhérents et a souhaité remettre son
drapeau associatif les propos sont
collectées par au rayon ce petit à petit
les pg se sont état aujourd'hui ce sont
des ca tm qui disparaissent c'est la vie
nous ne pouvons pas nous opposer à ce
qui se passe à odos décéda des nôtres on
ne peut que se souvenir des bons moments
nous avons passé ensemble c'est un
symbole qu'une association qui a oeuvré
pendant plus de 15 ans sur la ville
remet le drapeau les couleurs y aura
toujours une pensée qui sera toujours
dans la salle du conseil pour
quand les personnes viennent au conseil
va voir qu'il ya les couleurs qui sont
disposés çà souvenir l'événement attire
toujours à paris le salon de
l'agriculture s'ouvre ce samedi à
quelques jours du début de l'événement
direction auffargis la ferme de la
petite robe recevait la députée aurore
bergé pour lui faire part de ses
difficultés rencontrées dans la volonté
de production naturelle et respectueuse
de l'animal
les détails avec ce sujet de marylène
yapi chinois elles ont la charge noir et
les jours noirs des poules faverolles
des cochons gascon et du rock
la ferme de la petite aux gars auffargis
s'emploie depuis des années à
réintroduire des espèces menacées
dans un souci d'élevage le plus naturel
possible eric sens aux apparats en
exemple dans le bien-être animal jeu
réintroduit toutes ces espèces pour
montrer que avec une nourriture commune
un espace un environnement commun on a
quand même une spécificité génétique et
donc on a un goût différent en fonction
des espèces dernière victoire en date la
naissance de deux petits veaux au rock
une espèce préhistorique détendue et
sereine comme toutes leurs voisines des
tables par radio classique dont je peux
vous dire c'est fini pour la musique
classique nous sommes dans une dynamique
d'échangé de questionnements autour du
bien-être animal
aurore bergé a répondu à l'invitation de
l'éleveur une journée pour aborder un
sujet d'actualité
l'abattage ici tout est fait dans la vie
de l'animal pour qu' ils soient dans les
meilleures conditions possibles en
termes de reproduction et en termes
d'élevage mais à partir du moment où
l'animal est transportée jusqu'à son
abattage il ya un certain nombre de
questions qui se posent pour vérifier la
traçabilité la manière avec laquelle
l'animal va être considéré et jusqu'à
son abattage
la jeune association en faveur de
l'abattage des animaux dans la dignité
afad était présente pour apporter son
expertise
il n'y a aucun abattoirs aujourd'hui en
france qui est vraiment digne de ce
travail de qualité qui effectué alors il
ya des abattoirs qui travaillent bien
mais aujourd'hui le niveau il est quand
même largement en deçà de ce qui est de
ce qu'ils devraient pour trappe de bien
être animal
l'afad réfléchit à des abattoirs mobile
qui permettrait de supprimer le
transport de l'animal ou lui permettant
une fin de vie digne et sereine et
toujours sur ce thème de la cause
animale des militants de l'association
oiseaux police se sont réunis
hier devant la préfecture des yvelines à
versailles une quinzaine de membres
vêtus de masquer ces manifestants
dénoncent la présence d'animaux dans les
cirques
[Musique]
le groupe est moins connue aujourd'hui
mes 50 ans plus tard ange est toujours
là bonsoir mélanie poker pour ça la
formation de rock français ont entamé
une tournée de deux ans pour son
anniversaire elle s'arrête à la batterie
de guyancourt et oui et le groupe a même
sorti un nouvel album en 2010 huit
heureux c'est son titre et c'est le
quarante quatrième album du groupe
alors bien sûr les membres se sont
renouvelées que les mêmes il y en a un
qui est toujours là christian décamps 72
ans l'un des fondateurs est le chanteur
du groupe allard en 1969 ans j'ai créé
connaît la gloire dans les années
soixante dix il a fait notamment la
première partie de johnny hallyday en 72
il joue au mythique festival de reading
en 1973 et le même jour que genesis le
groupe de peter gabriel imaginait
grégory alors les années 70 ce sont ces
disques d'or récit d'un million d'albums
vendus anges c'est du rock progressif
[Musique]
alors pour les nostalgiques ou les
novices anges c'est ce vendredi 22
février à la batterie de guyancourt une
bonne occasion d'écouter la voix si
caractéristique de christian décamps
comme on viens de l'entendre
aujourd'hui il est accompagné de son
fils tristan thierry si doux benoît à
cazouls aînés et hassan hadji merci
mélanie poquet que l'on retrouvera la
présentation du 7-8 culture la culture à
l'honneur justement celle de la chine le
week-end dernier à verneuil-sur-seine la
commune accueillait la deuxième édition
du nouvel an chinois initiative de
l'école du dragon bleu qui enseigne les
arts martiaux et le kung fu
traditionnelle danse de lion et du
dragon géant est démonstrations étaient
au programme plus de mille personnes ont
participé à l'événement trouver le
meurtrier le but de la murder party sur
le thème de la saint-valentin à la salle
de la tour de voisins-le-bretonneux les
joueurs ont tenté dimanche de résoudre
l'énigme
retour sur ce grand jeu de rôle avec
patrick jacques de dixmude et manon
varaldo qui est le meurtrier
voici la question que les joueurs se
posent avec ce cluedo grandeur nature
pour la mortelle saint valentin c'est
une nouvelle murder party la 17e
organisé par la compagnie des tisseurs
de songe aujourd'hui on ce comédien qui
joue les suspects d'une cinquantaine d'
indices qui sont dissimulés dans
l'espace de covile les participants
doivent trouver l'assassin de valentin
la faune pour lancer le jeu un petit
film avec la victime est présentée aux
joueurs qu'il organisait donc une soirée
speed dating pour
j'en recherche d'amour visiblement là il
a reçu un appel avec d'une personne un
peu agressive
il le met en danger et
il ya quand même un peu comme quelque
chose d'un peu de catholiques sur cette
histoire là cette murder party a demandé
un mois et demi de préparation et la
participation de onze comédiens amateurs
et professionnels un vrai défi narratif
pour eux je m'intéresse au speed dating
et c'est dans ce cadre que j'ai atterri
ici donc je sais tu copies dont
évidemment c'est une
c'était un bon moyen de 2 doit produire
dans les soirées speed dating pour
observer ce qui s'y passe mais
malheureusement il s'est produit un
drame
nous nous avons les éléments qui de
notre vie mais nous n'avons pas plus
d'éléments que ça les joueurs déambule
dans l'espace de covile il tente de
résoudre le mystère et interrogent et
les protagonistes à technique c'est bien
écouter regarder robert bien trop bien
cibler les bons vins 10 et après ça
seuls 115 personnes étaient présentes
par session de jeu deux heures dans
quête de rebondissements d'un trig à
partir de 10 ans à la fin du set 8
journal belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]